-Hello, everyone and welcome
back to the captain's quarters.
If you watched last night's
"Closer Look,"
you may have noticed that
my parents were visiting,
and it was the first time
my father and the sea captain
were in the same room,
which was awkward,
as my dad is on the record
as not being a fan
of the captain.
-To be fair, Larry also
doesn't like the Beatles.
-That is a true fact
about my dad.
He doesn't like the Beatles.
But we made time for my father
and the sea captain
to hash it out, and at the end
of tonight's episode
we're going to show you
that exclusive conversation.
-Our discourse, like the sea,
got a bit rocky.
-Speaking of rocky waters --
-Forced segue!
-The President knows he
can't win in November
with a majority of votes,
so instead he's trying to
undermine the integrity
of the election
by sabotaging
the post office.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Throughout the entirety
of his term,
Donald Trump has
consistently been
the most unpopular President
in history.
It's easy to forget, but he's
been widely disliked
since day one of his campaign.
People might have thought
they liked the character
of Donald Trump
on "The Apprentice,"
but that's a little like
enjoying Buzz Lightyear
when you're watching
"Toy Story"
and then meeting
the Buzz Lightyear
in Times Square.
[ Inhales ]
"To infinity and let's get
this picture over.
I've got to take a dump, kid,
and it takes like 15 minutes
to get this suit off."
Trump has never once cracked
50% approval
in the Gallup
daily tracking poll,
which is unprecedented.
Even the "Cats" movie has
a 53% audience score
on Rotten Tomatoes,
although I guess
unlike the "Cats" movie,
the White House can't just
digitally blur out the [bleep].
Trump and the Republican Party
have largely given up
on the idea of persuading
a majority of voters
to side with them,
the way you normally would
in a healthy democracy.
The modern conservative movement
is a fundamentally
anti-majoritarian movement
based on excluding people,
not including them.
It's not a coincidence their
paragon owns private golf clubs.
The Republican Party
motto should be,
"Sorry, you're not on
the list."
Their only hope of gaining
and holding on to power
is through tactics like
gerrymandering,
voter suppression, the electoral
college, stacking the courts,
or colluding with foreign
governments, which is why
Trump has spent the last
four years cold-calling
random countries asking them
to help him cheat.
[ As Trump ] "Hello, Peru, do
you have any dirt on Joe Biden?
"Joe. Biden.
Loves trains.
Looks super cool on a bicycle."
Now, Trump got impeached
for that, of course.
So he's moved on
to his next scheme,
sabotaging the post office.
-New today,
the "Washington Post" reporting
a sweeping overhaul of
the U.S. Postal Service.
It was announced in a memo
late Friday
from Postmaster General
Louis DeJoy.
The "Post" writes, "The move
displaced two top executives
overseeing day-to-day
operations."
-This is coming as Democrats
are calling for an investigation
into DeJoy
and his operating measures
that some say have
slowed mail delivery service.
-That's right.
Late on Friday,
the Postal Service announced
a massive restructuring
that centers power around
the postmaster general,
Louis DeJoy, a Trump loyalist
who donated over $360,000
to the Trump campaign and
Republican National Committee.
And right off the bat
you know it's shady
because they did it
late on a Friday night.
Nothing good ever happens
Friday nights are for eating
cereal at 2:00 A.M.
and watching reruns of that
cop show starring
the guy who sells
reverse mortgages.
You're not gonna fool me by
pretending to be a cop.
I know you're here
to take my house.
Also, it's incredibly
suspicious to have
a right-wing businessman
and mega-donor in charge
of a non-partisan agency
like the Postal Service.
You think of postal workers as
charming friends and neighbors
straight out of Mayberry.
This is like if your town's
ice cream man
was replaced by Karl Rove.
"Here you go, kid, one bullet
pop, that will be $6,000."
They're made by Raytheon."
On top of that, DeJoy,
the former CEO
of a logistics company, also has
a massive conflict of interest.
According to his
financial disclosure,
he has anywhere from $30 million
to $75 million in assets
invested in competitors
to the post office,
which is absurd.
That's like finding out
the new president of PETA
is the Colonel.
"Your chickens will be safe
with me.
Oh, these legs and thighs are
nice and juicy --
not for eating!"
Now, Trump and DeJoy say
the changes are necessary
because the post office
is losing money.
In fact, you've probably heard
Trump complain about it
at one of his fake news
conferences.
-They've lost so much money
over the decades.
Nobody's ever -- nothing loses
money like the post office.
It's been losing massive
amounts of money
over the last number
of decades.
Massive amounts of money.
This is not something new.
This is something that's been
taking place for a long time.
It loses a tremendous amount
of money.
-Okay, first of all,
that's wrong.
The Postal Service turned
a profit as recently as 2006.
Second, you're the last person
on Earth who should be
complaining about someone else
losing money.
You lost a billion,
one billion dollars,
in the '80s and '90s,
which was more than
any single taxpayer
in the country lost.
And you also somehow managed
to lose money on casinos,
which I didn't even think
was possible.
I mean, casinos rake in cash.
Last time I went to a casino,
I spent an hour playing a game
called The Money Eater.
It was just a giant hole
you threw your chips into
and when you ran out,
it just screamed "Feed me!"
Also it makes no sense to say
the post office loses money.
It's a public service.
You never hear people say the
fire department loses money.
We had start charging $50
per cat rescued from a tree.
Of course, most owners I know,
most cat owners,
would also pay $50
if you left it in the tree.
"She'll come down when she's
hungry, but I would love
for her to learn a lesson.
Now, Trump is not the only
Republican politician
to complain that the post office
loses money.
It's been a right-wing
talking point for years,
especially among those
who want to privatize
the postal service.
The Trump administration
itself rolled out a plan
to do just that in 2018,
and right-wing billionaire
Charles Koch has been
campaigning to privatize
the postal service for decades,
which is shocking and craven
given that the postal service
is literally
in the Constitution.
In fact, it's as old as
the republic itself.
So there was already
a years-long right-wing effort
to privatize one of America's
most cherished
public institutions,
the Postal Service.
Then came Trump, and he was
joined in his crusade
by a bunch of soulless
right-wing husks
who want to turn every
post office into one of those
combination
fast food restaurants.
"Yeah, I'll take ten stamps and
a Doritos Locos Taco Supreme."
And look, it's absolutely true
that the post office
is struggling right now,
thanks in large part
to the pandemic and a decrease
in first-class mail volume,
even though package deliveries
have surged.
But there's another reason the
post office loses money.
And it's actually the fault of
the very same Republicans
who are now complaining that
the post office loses money.
-In 2006, the Republican-led
Congress did pass a law
that affected the USPS's
bottom line.
It required the Postal Service
to prefund health benefits
for future retirees.
We talked to experts who said
that because of this law,
USPS had to pay more
than $6 billion
that it really wasn't ready for.
So before the law, USPS paid out
these benefits as they came due.
And they point out that no other
agency has these restrictions.
So without the law,
the postal service
would definitely be
better off.
-That's right.
In 2006, Republicans forced
the post office to pay
75 years
of health fund benefits
in advance, which is insane.
Who knows what postal service
will even look like in 75 years?
Might just be a chip
in your brain
and you'll check the mail
by winking.
"Oh, damn it, my student loan
officer found me."
I'm -- [ Laughing ]
I'm really bad at winking.
So without that law --
I can't get my mail anymore.
So without that law, it's very
likely the post office
could have been operating at
a profit before the pandemic.
In fact, from 2003 to 2006,
the Postal Service actually
did operate at a profit,
until the 2006 law
wrecked their finances.
-From 2003 through 2006,
USPS recorded a total
$9.3 billion profit.
That all changed
at the end of 2006.
Enter the Postal Accountability
and Enhancement Act,
which was passed by the
Republican-controlled Congress
and signed into law by
President George W. Bush.
It required the post office
to calculate
all of its retiree pension
and health care costs
for the next 75 years,
including for people
it hadn't even hired yet,
and put away enough over the
next ten years to cover them.
To put this in perspective,
that would be like
you only working from
age 18 to 28
and then expecting you
to live on that income
until you were 103
years old.
-Yeah, exactly.
Imagine working for ten years
then living off that until
you're 103.
The only person who's ever
done it is Rudy Giuliani.
Without this law, the Postal
Service would have actually
recorded operating profits
in the last six years.
Instead, it's now in
a dire financial situation
thanks to a requirement
that virtually no other
government agency or company
has to deal with.
-There is Congressional
legislation that required them
to prefund their pension
liabilities in a way
that basically no one else
has to,
which has created an enormous
burden on their balance sheet.
-They're definitely in trouble.
And what you mentioned,
the prefunding requirement,
literally having to pay for --
or set aside money
for the workers that haven't
even been born yet
that will be coming in
75 years down the road
is the primary reason
prior to the pandemic.
-Just think about that.
They had to pay for retirement
benefits for workers
who hadn't
even been born yet.
That's like going out on
a first date and saying,
"I had a great time tonight.
What do you say
we go back to my place
and open up
a 529 college savings plan
for our eventual children?"
It made no sense.
And it weakened the postal
service dramatically.
Now the post office
desperately needs a bailout
of as much as
$25 billion from Congress.
Which if you ask me,
we should immediately do.
$25 billion is nothing compared
to the $740 billion
Pentagon budget.
You're telling me you can't
find a billionaire to buy
an f-15 or two?
Richard Branson definitely
has the vibe of a guy
who wants to wind to blow
through his hair
at 1,800 miles an hour.
And yes, I say that joke
knowing my hair
is getting more Bransony
by the day.
And yet, rather than spend
the money needed
to shore up of one his country's
most vital
and cherished institutions,
Trump and the GOP
are using the financial
situation as an opportunity
to destroy the post office
for their own political gain.
Just this weekend, "Politico"
reported that Trump's aides
are exploring
executive actions
to curb voting by mail,
including everything from
directing the postal service
to not deliver certain ballots
to stopping local officials
from counting them
after Election Day.
That is chilling.
The President thinks
he can just decide
which votes count
and which ones don't.
Soon he's going to start
crossing out ballots himself
and we'll all know because
he'll sign them himself.
Whether or not Trump
actually succeeds
in stopping mail-in voting
is almost beside the point.
Either way,
he's sowing confusion,
setting up lengthy
court battles,
and laying the groundwork to
claim the results are disputed,
even if they're not.
He's made that as clear
as possible.
-I don't want to see
an election --
you know, so many years
I've been watching elections --
and they say the projected
winner or the winner
of the election.
I don't want to see that
take place in a week
after November 3rd,
or a month,
or frankly, with litigation
and everything else
that can happen, years.
Years. Or you never even
know who won the election.
I want to have the result
of the election.
I don't want to be waiting
around for weeks and months.
And literally, potentially,
if you really did it right,
years,
because you'll never know.
I want to have the election.
But I also don't want to have to
wait for three months
and then find out that
the ballots are all missing
and the election
doesn't mean anything.
That's what's going to happen.
-It's only going to happen
if you make it happen.
Trump's like a loan shark
telling you,
"I'd hate to see your
thumbs get broken."
We can have a safe,
successful election
if we just adequately fund
and protect the post office.
You won't have to wait
years for results.
But even if we did,
why are you complaining?
Waiting around is like the
one thing you're good at.
Your favorite sport is
98% waiting around.
You spend most of your days
sitting in your bedroom
watching TV and loitering
on the White House lawn
like you're waiting
for a cross-town bus.
You should be smoking
a cigarette, saying,
"I should have taken --
I should have taken the M-66.
Couldn't decide how to hold
my cigarette."
What do you think,
Trump like this,
or Trump like this?"
Either way.
Trump is openly trying to
disrupt timely delivery
of the mail ahead of
a November election
that will almost certainly
rely on an unprecedented surge
in mail-in balloting
because of the deadly plague
he failed to stop.
DeJoy has already announced
major operational changes
last month, including
slower mail delivery,
post offices have been
slashing hours,
local union leaders
and carriers say
mail is piling up in offices
unscanned and unsorted.
It's gotten so bad
a Democratic Senator
is finally opening an
investigation into the delays.
-We have folks who rely on the
Postal Service for our checks,
Social Security checks,
paychecks,
prescription medicines
that are coming in.
I'm hearing from folks,
letter carriers
and postal workers that
are saying they're seeing
piles of mail they've never seen
before in their post offices.
-That's insane.
Mail's not supposed to pile up
in post offices,
it's supposed to pile up
on your kitchen table.
until one day
a mustachioed stranger
comes to take your house away.
"Time to pay the piper,
old friend."
"But you said you weren't going
to take my house."
"I fibbed.
I distracted you with my
mustache, and I fibbed."
And letting mail pile up
is heresy
for postal workers
who pride themselves
on timely mail delivery.
Remember their motto,
"Neither snow nor rain
nor heat nor gloom of night"?
That's why Trump would have been
a terrible mailman.
He would have seen one cloud
on the horizon
and dumped his mailbag
in the East River
and headed for the OTB.
"They'll never catch me.
Oh, no!
Oh, no, since when does
paper float?"
This is all Trump has left.
He and the Republican Party have
given up on fairly winning
a majority of votes,
so now they're trying
to undermine
the election itself.
Because Trump knows that if we
have a safe and fair election
in which everyone
can easily participate,
he has no chance of
being the --
-Projected winner or the
winner of the election.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
-So excited to hear
your feedback, Larry.
-Well, what I like about
"A Closer Look"
is that they're funny.
-Mm-hmm.
-But the jokes are about
the news.
Whereas when you talk,
it's not about anything.
-Uh-huh.
-At best, it's puns,
which are the lower form
of comedy.
-Okay.
-And another thing,
and don't take this
the wrong way.
-Hmm.
-You sound like Will Forte.
-Love him.
-And I was always
more of a Bill Hader guy.
-Hader, hmm.
-Or even Jason Sudeikis.
-I guess my only retort
to that would be,
[bleep] you, Larry!
♪♪
-We've been talking
City Harvest since COVID began,
and now more than ever
they need your help
feeding New York families.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.